♪ [intro music] ♪
[Max] Give me one minute,
and I'll show you
how reCAPTCHA Enterprise
can keep fraudulent actors away
from your online business.
Each year, billions
of logins are attempted
with stolen credentials.
By creating synthetic accounts
or taking over real accounts,
hackers can post false comments
or commit fraudulent transactions
on your site.
reCAPTCHA Enterprise learns
by monitoring real traffic on your site.
reCAPTCHA Enterprise
uses machine learning
to assign a score to each request
based on how likely it is legitimate.
You can use the score
and choose to take action on the request
or let it through.
For example,
you can enforce two-factor authentication
for such requests at the login page.
If the user successfully authenticates,
you can then annotate
the request as legitimate.
This will improve reCAPTCHA's
future predictions for your site.
However, if you receive
a credit card chargeback,
you can annotate the request
as fraudulent.
In addition to the score,
reCAPTCHA Enterprise returns reason codes
that can help you take the right action.
For example,
if the reason indicates an automated bot,
you might throttle the request
or send posts to the moderators.
reCAPTCHA Enterprise works with backends
running on third-party clouds,
on-premises, and Google Cloud.
It also supports mobile
as well as web applications.
So next time you're looking
to keep fraudulent bots away
from your online business
without extra friction,
take a minute to explore
reCAPTCHA Enterprise.
To learn more,
check out
cloud.google.com/recaptcha-enterprise.
♪ [outro music] ♪